[Aplausos]
[Música]
vengativo mamita jamón a yupanqui me
digan chiste activo con agua un ataque
con ataque quien gana maná estaban
difícil para que medirá con chile
remake una o ambas que una marca sea
justa
catina canchilla tanto la justicia
lo que ustedes acaban de escuchar son
los sonidos de las flautas con los que
he crecido y los que me han dejado el
legado cultural a través de la música
en mi familia somos nueve hermanos y dos
hermanas crecí insertada en mis raíces
del pueblo kichwa andina donde la música
nos mantuvo cada día hundidos en nuestra
identidad con y harina el recorrido por
miles de parques
plazas del ecuador
compartiendo siempre nuestra música
ancestral a cambio de la solidaridad de
nuestro pueblo que con generosidad nos
ha permitido vivir hasta en los momentos
más difíciles ahora viajamos por todo el
mundo cantando y contando las historias
de latinoamérica dando a conocer las
luchas que se han librado por más de 500
años para defender su derecho a
sobrevivir a desarrollarse sin perder
nuestra cultura sin perder nuestra raíz
pero siempre con la música y los cantos
que yo
para nosotros los quichuas la
cosmovisión andina es la filosofía
integral
que da cuenta la indisoluble hermandad
entre todo lo existente
en la naturaleza la especie humana y la
pachamama la madre tierra somos un todo
y dependemos estrechamente los unos de
los otros no hay seres superiores ni
seres inferiores y por ello reconocemos
que la especie humana no es sino una de
las tantas partes de la naturaleza y no
dueñas de ella
en nuestra filosofía el universo está
compuesto por tres mundos el hananpacha
que es el mundo de los dioses el taita
imbabura la mama cotacachi todos los
surcos las cascadas los ríos es el mundo
de los saberes el de nuestros símbolos
sagrados el de nuestra referencia y
memoria elementos que dan equilibrio a
la existencia de nuestra vida
él ukhupacha el mundo de los antepasados
de nuestros ancestros que nos legaron el
patrimonio
y que hoy tenemos el mandato de cuidar
cada una de ellas
kaipacha es el mundo actual y que
estamos haciendo por este mundo
y que la lógica del mercado occidental
lo está destruyendo y amenazando con
hacer desaparecer de la faz de la tierra
en esta larga trayectoria artística
descubrí que a través de los cantos se
puede ayudar a salvar este
porque el canto nos hace amar a la
lengua
una lengua que sigue amenazada desde
aquellos tiempos coloniales en los que
los llamaban yang así me o la lengua que
nos sirve de una manera despectiva lo
tratan y humillante razón por la que
muchos padres y madres quichuas
decidieron no enseñarlos a sus hijos el
idioma ancestral
negar la lengua materna es igual que
cortarse el cabello todo con tal de
lograr que sus hijos sean aceptados
dentro de un sistema educación nacional
que es enajenante racista y excluyente
luego de vivir 15 años fuera de nuestra
iacta tierra
regrese junto a jan ida y harina a
ecuador a crear la casa de artes y our
world hermanos de sangre
y con esta casa nos centramos a la
producción de varios proyectos
educativos relacionados con el
conocimiento la revitalización y la
difusión de nuestro idioma especialmente
en la población quechua de otavalo de si
nos proyectamos hacia la creación de
reír la recuperación de identidad a
través del aprendizaje de la música y
del canto chizzo luego de tres años de
trabajo con los niños y niñas de las
comunidades obtuvimos los primeros
importantes resultados y nos dimos
cuenta
que los niños empezaron a valorar en
alto grado la importancia de pensar de
hablar y de cantar chizzo para recuperar
su identidad y muchos de ellos a su
temprana edad hacen de la música parte
esencial de sus vidas incluso muchos de
ellos piensan ser músicos de profesión
en el programa de vinculación
comunitaria de nuestra casa de artes
viajamos por muchas comunidades de
imbabura
y me complace saber que el interés de
aprender el idioma quichua ya no es
solamente de la población indígena sino
de una población diversa mestiza pues
así desarrollan habilidades lingüísticas
extienden su conocimiento con palabras
que no existen en los diccionarios
normales y aprenden elementos
importantes de otras culturas en un
verdadero proceso de interculturalidad
la razón por la que me embarqué en este
proyecto a pesar de tener un sistema
educativo bilingüe es que aún no
contamos con suficiente información
material didáctico para sustentar esta
educación
que no se reduzca solamente a la
traducción de un idioma a otro las
palabras
sino que se comprenda que junto a la
lengua deben haber aprendizajes
simultáneos la música el canto las
danzas y otras expresiones culturales
que son parte ineludible de la educación
del ser humano
hoy en la casa de artes estamos
produciendo el manual probablemente el
primero sobre el método del violín
andino que poco se conoce sus diferentes
afinaciones vivir ritmos que solamente
se conoce en las comunidades andinas el
proyecto macro será escribir la
metodología de la música andina y esto
permitirá un acercamiento más técnico y
estético a nuestros ritmos tradicionales
la gestión independiente tiene muchas
caras unas bastante satisfactorias otras
no tanto y esto me ha implicado un
trajinar muy fuerte en el que a veces
mis proyectos solamente se han quedado
en hermosos sueños
sin embargo estoy consciente de que si
yo no lo hago si nosotros los quichuas
no lo hacemos nadie lo va a hacer
y una cara muy agradable de esta
experiencia ha sido mi vinculación con
diferentes espacios educativos y
culturales y especialmente con
universidades fuera del país gracias a
ello nuestro proyecto sigue funcionando
a las vinculaciones y que cree en los
proyectos nuestros
y gracias a estos puentes seré parte del
simposio internacional de lenguas y
culturas de américa latina en ohio eeuu
la música y la artesanía otavaleña ha
sido reconocida en el mundo entero pero
para ello hemos tenido tenido que
trabajar muy fuerte
yo misma soy una protagonista y un
producto de este proceso con irina
empecé a cantar a los 6 años grupo que
ha sido una llave y que ha abierto
muchas puertas para que nosotros los
otavaleños seamos reconocidos de los
cinco continentes
junto a esta agrupación artística
he sido parte de muchos reconocimientos
aquí en el ecuador y también en
norteamérica
nosotros hemos sido los ganadores en el
2005 al premio de la mejor música del
mundo y los premios nami de neira
american music awards no sé si alguno de
ustedes de alguna vez de su vida lo
escucharon nosotros también somos parte
de la identidad nacional y del
pentagrama nacional
un encuentro que nos permitió conocer a
muchos países muchos pueblos originarios
con similares problemáticas en el mundo
y allí presentamos nuestro trabajo en
quiché
importante espacio que nos ha abierto
para presentar nuestro trabajo en
diferentes teatros importantes del mundo
como el kennedy center lincoln center
los teatros de broadway
el museo del smithsonian escuelas
colegios universidades que piden
estudiar a latinoamérica y
específicamente al quichua
en las residencias artísticas con harina
y en esta larga experiencia he aprendido
que si se quiere hacer realidad nuestros
sueños y las utopías tenemos que creer
en nuestro trabajo
tenemos que creer en la capacidad que
tenemos como mujeres como mujeres
quichuas como artistas como dignos seres
humanos que tenemos ese legado cultural
aprendí que volver a la tierra es
importante si no quieren que nos y no
queremos que nos borren de la historia y
que es necesario pagar a la tierra todo
lo que ella nos da
por eso estamos aquí de vuelta por eso
yo estoy en mi tierra
porque mis cantos no son sino cantos de
mi tierra de mi pachamama expresados en
mi voz por eso volví a soñar y a parir
la primera orquesta intercultural de
otavalo junto a taquiri ya más de 20
niños de las diferentes comunidades
pues hay que empezar a reconstruir la
historia con ellos
por eso estoy volviendo siempre
por eso voy a empezar a reconstruir a
través del idioma nuestra identidad
por eso mi voz sirve a través de mi voz
se escuchan las voces de nuestras mamás
y mi sueño más grande
y entendernos con ustedes con la misma
facilidad que yo me entiendo en el
idioma de ustedes
[Aplausos]